how's it going guys matt here with go
tech tutorials just want to show you a
quick tip today and that's
all about controlling some of the things
that start up with your computer i do
this
for things like updating certain repos
and updating libraries for my
programming stuff
so i just want to show you this real
quick and there's a lot i could like get
into a lot of side tangents on this
about how programs do it but i'm gonna
kind of avoid all that and just show you
this uh startup folder thing that seems
to have kind of
left public knowledge a little bit
alright so we're running windows here
obviously windows 10
if you want anything to run at the start
of your computer well there are ways to
do that
like your software down here of course
you can go to the settings of whatever
software and
if you're working with something like
that it would advise using the settings
they have within it there's always
something that says run at startup or
something like that and if you don't
want it you can uncheck it
so let it handle that usually makes a
registry entry
but there's another way for things that
you just want to like custom
run and that is the startup now i
usually just
go to run or press windows r
and then type shell start all this does
it open up my other screen all this does
is it opens up this folder
from your profile to roaming microsoft
windows start menu program start
so once you're in here you can put any
runnable files
into here and it will try to run them so
you can see i have a batch file here and
it says update bc pkg lives i think i
might have mentioned this in another
video but
this is something that i find really
useful because basically what this does
it runs the script anytime i reboot
anytime i start up so
i know that when i get up in the morning
and boot up my pc
it's going to update to the latest
version of all my libraries and all that
stuff so we can go look at this
batch files are a little beyond the
scope of this but i'll at least show you
this bcpkg one in case you're curious if
i hit open it just runs it
as you can see it does all this stuff
and let's look at the code because
that's what we do here
why is there no open width on this okay
we'll just go to edit and make custom
batch commands and throw them in the
startup folder to do whatever you want
so let's just go through this one real
quick first of all we turn echo off
give a little title that just controls
this title right here
and then we start running commands we're
just putting them one per line first of
all i'm going to change directory to
where vcpkg is now this is on a
different drive than my c
drive so i now have to do this to switch
to
the drive then i'm just going to echo
now all this does is it spits out
some text into your console so i'm
saying pulling from get and then i run
pull now you can leave these out if you
don't want all
the uh extra what does sun do not work
properly here there's only one undo
backup with no paddle
so no pad so bad okay so i'll just say
boolean okay
good enough so we do a git so let's
start over so after changing to the
directory or we see pkg is we run git
pull
now get pool isn't going to work
normally in windows
and this is where i start getting into
random side things because you know
what tends to happen is i'll do stuff
i'll kind of walk through and explain it
and then people have a million questions
because it doesn't work for them
and it's because there's prerequisite
knowledge and
that's so i try to cover the
prerequisite knowledge so that people
that are new to this don't get lost or
know where to look if they want to find
out more
all right so running git pool won't work
on windows right until you add it to
your environments of course you have to
install it but installing it
if you install it and add it to your
path i guess you could check out cmake
episode 10 i think i talk about that a
lot
uh you basically need to add git to your
path so i'll leave
rather than just explain it again i'll
leave a link to that video above
somewhere and you can check it out
if you want to see how to do all the
path stuff so okay we'll continue on
run get pull and then after pulling the
new updates
we're going to call another batch file
and it's the bootstrap vc package
manager
dot bat that comes with vc package
manager now this essentially rebuilds it
and it's
it's smart in a way that if you've
already built the latest one and you
have no new
updates it's not going to do anything
it's just going to say a hearty update
already updated or something like that
so it's a pretty harmless command
it's not going to hurt anything even if
you don't have any updates from the
cable
but if you do you need to run this
sometimes in order to get the new
binaries or whatever it may be all right
and then i do a little
upgrade here now this is a pretty
standard command that you normally run
all the time
so normally when you go to update vc
package manager you go to it you're on
vc package manager upgrade no dry run
i guess if you have it if you have vc
package manager in your path
you don't need to navigate to it first
but you still need to navigate to the
right folder for the git pull
unless you make this command more robust
robust like you tell it which path which
i don't remember how to do that
off-topic
so i do the change direct directory all
right so normally when you upgrade bc
package manager on your own
you do a githull you do this call thing
if you need to and you do not
try run upgrade and this just does it
all for you then after all that we're
going to integrate install again just to
make sure
go here pause pause we'll make the
window not
close so yeah this is just one sample of
a batch file i run every update so you
can make batch files to do
any specific little things maybe you
want your calendar to pop up or
something or maybe you want some custom
app that you've wrote
or written to pop up you can put it in
the startup folder so
that's the big tip to just help make
your day a little easier
for really this intended for noobs
pretty much anybody that knows a decent
amount
about programming and stuff will
probably already know this or just about
id and stuff
is a pretty standard it trick but uh
yeah just wanted to get it out there
let me know your tips for saving time
and doing things automatically
and maybe i'll make another episode
about other little tricks we can use to
get stuff done
and save us time alright catch you in
the next one peace out
[Music]
you